。
嗯。
咱们开始上课啊。首先为什么选这部电影呢？有几方面的原因？第一，这部电影啊当年算是新人阵容啊，包括导演也是第一次做电影导演。当时呢确实这部电影呢杀出重围啊创制创造了一个记录，不管是票房还是口碑啊双丰收。第二呢啊这个电影也当奠定了我司是吧？开心麻花。
的江湖地位啊一举奠定了开心麻花的名号。第三呢嗯是这种强势定类型喜剧啊。嗯在后来的很长一段时间啊，都是在院线成为了主流。他把强类型呃喜剧呢又带回到我们生活当中了。从商业角的角度，还还有从这个片子的观赏性的角度。
无疑是一个非常成功的作品啊，即便是呃有些同学觉得哎呀没有深度啊，但是呢呃对于咱们绝大部分同学来说，咱们现在要进行商业片的创作啊，咱们是需要学习的啊，艺术是多样的啊。看一部电影老规矩，二话不说，不论主题，不论类型，不论主角，啥也别闹，先拉几拍。
这部电影呢类型非常的清清晰啊，结构非常的简单啊。这一点咱们承认呃，所以说评分确实即便是再好笑是吧？让你再快乐也不那么高啊，第一拍第一分钟开始啊，直接进了现状。有些同学说老师你不是之前说如果一个电影有两条时间线，那条小的时间线。
其实是前史吗？其实不应该列入正文吗？我们先学一个知识点啊，第一节拍我们就先学一个知识点。就说正常来说，如果电影有两条实战线，那条很短很短的，基本上就是个前史或者是个帽子。我们说一个电影要从现状开始啊，但是今天学一个新的知识点，穿越系不是这样的啊，穿越系的现状。
就是现在他因为第对现状不满，他才穿越的穿越系一虑，现在就是他的现状。因为穿越系理论上不是两条时间线，所有的穿越都是想象啊，他对现状不满才会去穿越。所以第一场第一个节拍就是现状啊，就是启程转折的起，就是现状就是当下从第一分钟到第12分钟。
展现的是夏洛对现状不满，他缺的是面子。通过去参加婚礼呢，他想要找回自己的面子，结果呢又丢了更大的面子。
这就是第一坨戏。同时在第一坨戏里还做了一件什么事情呢？
做了各个伙伴、对手以及爱情的登场啊，就是各种人物在第一场戏里都登场了，甚至要做了一个伏笔，要呼应高中时期的人物。所以说这里做了一个人物登场，提前做了。另外呢把目标也提前展现了，就是他对秋雅不死心啊，我们叫要70目标啊，70目标也展现了。因为在第二幕里他要追求这个目标啊，这个伏笔在这里也打好了。
我们说第一个节拍就12分钟啊，这在一个商业电电影当中是比较罕见的。哎一般来说，商业电影的第一幕节拍会比较多，因为信息量大啊，但是今这个戏里面第一坨戏12分钟啊，展现的东西很多。但是在同一拍里，第二拍第13分钟她被马冬梅堵在厕所以后，她从厕所里走出来啊，说了个咒语。
这种如愿以偿的戏要有咒语，说出了他的咒语，其实就是说出了他的愿望啊，像所有的穿越题材啊，都会有一个比较有仪式感的咒语啊，然后冥冥之中就有一个人惩罚你，哎，你不是要吗？那我给你啊。但是在这部戏当中呢略微有点轻飘飘啊，学点知识点啊，你自己写的时候，这个咒语可以写的重一点，就是他把愿望可以再明确一点。
这是第二节拍，也就是从这里开始啊，他说出咒语之后，他就穿越到了高中的教室啊，他开始当然以为这是个梦啊，这场戏列还做了一件什么事情呢？因为这这个电影伙伴对手爱情都很多，所以这里继续要强化人设。由于他以为这是个梦呢，他决定放肆一把啊，什么打老师呀，强吻秋雅呀，同学们在这里注意所有的如愿以偿。我们说召唤。
都是这个穿越这个冤王召唤你了。但是呢我们的主角会不相信这是真的，这叫拒绝召唤。他的拒绝召唤是什么？他的拒绝召唤是他要回去，他说再见各位，然后后来发现拒绝召唤失败了，然后又放火跳楼，然后再次拒住绝召唤。他以为跳楼能回去看一下这场戏。
都我给你捎点纸过去。
拒绝召唤啊，这是第二拍。第三拍。
也就是第20分钟第20分钟啊，他从医院醒来啊，发现自己真的穿越了。这里确实是1997年第四拍在第22分钟啊，我们说进入第二幕要有仪式感。主角正式踏上征程啊，看一下进入第二幕要干什么？进入第二幕要放BGM对吧？第五拍开始第23分钟啊，进入第二幕BGM响情进入第二幕之后呢，这部戏先做的是伙伴的登场啊。首先这三人组是重要。
重要伙伴啊，接下来你看啊所有的伙伴都登了，重新登了一遍场，大家看一下，想开点看看啊。
马冬梅秋雅啊，就是爱情和骑视对手啊，也做一下登场，或者是7势目标和后期目标。你可以这么理解啊。我们后面都会讲到这两个人是干嘛的。接着就是他妈和校长这一整坨戏全都是一起的啊，通过校园生活的展开。我们说这部戏一句话或者是什么？或者是简单讲是什么？不就是夏洛回到高中嘛，那回到高中之后抽烟呀，打架呀，妈妈帮他解除开机。
开除危机啊，这三坨戏都是一个节拍伙伴团队逐个登场啊。第六拍25分钟，我们说第二幕伙伴们都登完场了，主角开始宣布自己的目标了。好，就是这句话啊。主角展现了他的第一个目标，也就是他的外部目标，或者我们成为起始目标叫什么？
就要追求涯，明白吧？虽然这里看起来啊看起来是夏洛在赚钱脑，但是这低流拍这场戏非常重要的是展现起始目标啊来。
进入。
第七拍也就是第27分钟在课堂是一场课堂的戏啊，王老师在讲课啊，夏洛就开始要换座，其实就是开始追追逐他的起始目标。因为上一坨戏我们已经把我们的起始目标明确出来了，就是我要追秋牙，下一场戏肯定要去实现这个目标啊，推进这个目标，同时得罪了本片的最大的反派。
当然我们不能称之为反派啊，我们称之为对手，最终的最大的对手啊，总boss总boss是谁啊？总boss是圆华啊，圆华，我们看一下这妥西吧啊，第27分钟我们说产出目标之后，我们在课堂上推进这个目标。
首先先把总boss得罪了，但其实故事的中前部主要对手是谁啊？冬梅。
来同学们回答我，圆华作为故事的总boss是后场发力。前半程我们的主角追寻自己的目标，他的主要对手是谁啊？是马冬梅，非常好啊，非常好，非常好啊。一定要搞清楚现实主义题材。由于没有大坏蛋，就是像这种校园戏爱情戏。这个待会儿咱们再去讲啊，如何拆解对手，没有大坏蛋的情况下怎么做。
怎么做对手？他的前中前部的对手啊是马冬梅总boss肯定是袁华啊，因为袁华是从头扑到尾的。袁华做了很多次攻击啊。好，那这就是第七个节拍，也就是说这场课堂戏夏洛正式开始追寻自己的起始目标，也就是秋雅啊得罪了主要对手袁华。因为后面袁华要发力。同时呢前期对手马冬美已经开始跟他对抗了。
第八拍属于我们这个戏最出彩的反派啊，我们看一下这坨戏好。
点到为止就可以了啊，我说一下啊，这场戏可不是废戏啊，咱们不能说袁华每次出现都带着一剪眉，咱们就觉得这是故意来招笑的。，不你先别笑，你听我说来，我在给你们讲故事节拍的时候，不管是讲斯奈德的节拍，还是讲我们的那个那个节拍，还是讲我们的十5步，来在第二幕，我们说。
即便主要对手没有发力，但是我们在第二幕也要布局主要对手或者是最后总boss的威胁了，对不对？记不记得这句话，虽然这场戏很搞笑，但是你如果把袁华理解为大反派的话，他在这场戏已经开始展现决心和威胁了。你们能理解我在说什么吗？就这场戏是有他的作用的。
虽然他很搞笑，但你不能觉得他是场纯搞笑的戏。我们讲过在第二幕要开始展现反派的威胁。那么在这里，袁华作为最终的总boss，他已经开始展现他的决心了，他说我一定要干掉他呀。他已经展现决心了，后面叫人赌他那是后面的他的动作。在这里他已经展现他决心和威胁了。
好吧，来来第九拍第33分钟啊，主角开始开挂啊，开什么挂音乐金手指啊，作曲做就是当歌手的当歌星的金手指开始开挂。我们说主角呃这个穿越系这种如愿以偿的戏，他如愿以偿了之后先要尝甜头，尝甜头往往是要开金手指的，明白吗？
如愿以偿的戏，大部分都是要开新手指的。咱们这个主角开的金手指是什么？当歌星对吧？当歌星，利用这个信息时间差当歌星。
是第九拍开始发现的啊，然后嘞借着他这个做歌星啊，借着他开始作曲啊，又玩了一轮蒙太奇。我们看一眼这个蒙太奇啊，待会儿我们总结一下这个戏为什么蒙太奇这么多，大家先别着急啊，我们稍微瞄一眼这个蒙太奇啊。
散落在天涯。第九个拍这坨戏主要是展现金手指啊，但是由于他的金手指是搞音乐，所以呢这歌的这个这这个其实就版权都买了，版权都已经租了，是吧？就在这个过程中又把配角的人设又强化了一遍。同学们理解一下啊，就在这里啊，他由于配角确实挺多的，而且都是麻花非常优秀的喜剧演员。
所以在这里又强化了一遍配角啊，我们并没有觉得奇怪。虽然其实。
就有点那个了有点晚了，但是并不奇怪啊，觉得还是挺舒服的啊。来第1拍第37分钟这场戏又很重要，稍微看一下这场戏的两个镜头，一点没有要来了啊，今天还不敢在学校里，明目张胆的对你怎么样？
下在吗？大家好，我是三年二班的夏洛。我专门为你创作了一首歌曲，趁着午休唱歌歌。
将梦想仗剑走天涯。
这场戏啊这场戏啊反派反派再一次伴随着一剪梅登场，但是已经把这个威胁逐步逼近了啊。为什么我说这场戏要单独看一下呢？在第二幕的中前部，主角是要爽的。在这在主角爽的同时，要把反派提前登场，是为了平衡这种爽，对不对啊？
记不记得啊？我们说第二幕主角得呃主角得到金手指或者主角在呃这个这个如愿以偿后是要爽一段时间的。但是我们这时候会安排，虽然反派还没有进攻你，但是我们安排反派的威胁，提前暴露，是为了平衡这种爽。那这场戏就完美诠释了这个平衡，完美诠释了这个平衡。为什么呢？他把这两件事情捡在一起。
懂吗？这个小技巧是我们自己要学的，就主角春风得意，跟反派几锣密鼓可以剪在同一场里。能明白我在说什么吗？你们咱们同学写戏的时候啊，由于是按照是吧？按照节拍学的，或者是按照步骤写的。在最开始的时候啊，略微会有点降气啊，会就是钉是钉膀是嘛啊，就是会略微有点降气，也不影响什么啊，因为剪辑会再把它剪在一起的。
但是你如果写的时候，你就直接把这两场戏对比着写，对吧？或者是你看人家这个是肯定不是剪辑写的，是编剧就这么写的。因为人家有扣啊。那个袁华刚说完，他在学校还不敢明目张胆对对你怎么样，然后这边马上就开始明目张胆对他怎么样，他就会把这个危机感放大啊，这种对比感放大，这个平衡放大，对不对？你你你可以研究一下这种啊学到点学到一点是一点啊。
就是夏洛的这个金手指啊，已经几乎征服了所有人啊，包括秋雅啊，秋雅已经被他征服了啊，除了马马冬梅秋雅已经被征服了。第1一排第39分钟一场很小的一个节拍，但是也比较重要。夏洛参加唱歌比赛得奖啊，其实就是继续放大这个金手指为后面他要挨揍做铺垫啊，继续放大金手指啊，第十一节拍就是参加歌唱比赛。那个双节棍啊。
得奖。
然后第十二拍自行车车轮事件啊，夏洛要送秋雅回家啊，几乎就要成功了啊。然后再一次被马冬梅打败啊，我说中前部的主要对手是马冬梅啊，马冬梅现在还没灭掉，这自行车事件又被马冬梅打败了。
然后第十三拍呃，这个夏洛想到对策如何灭掉马冬梅，就是鼓励大春去追求马冬梅。这场戏非常的重要。第十三拍夏洛鼓励大春去追求马冬梅。这场戏有好几个作用。第一，消灭了前期对手大春追到马冬梅的话，马冬梅这个前期对手不就消消灭了吗？
然后那后期他的目标是什么？前期目标是追求秋雅，秋雅得手的时候，后期的目标是追求马冬梅。但那追求马冬梅的时候，你前期这件事就埋下隐患了啊。我们说这个设计啊是非常巧妙的啊，算是编剧的基本功之一。也就是说写到这儿，你做一个合格的编剧，你必须得写这场戏来到第44分钟啊，第1四拍。
威胁第一次来啊，主要对手第一次发力元华第一次发力，陈凯陈凯就来赌夏洛啊，就把夏洛给揍了。是谁救了夏洛呢？是马冬梅和王老师啊，而且在这里呢铺垫开始铺垫马冬梅对夏洛的付出。后面他要出事的啊。第15拍也就是第49分钟啊，这里呢是一组戏，首先是马冬梅先丑人多作怪。
然后被秋雅给压制了，然后对账的是什么呢？袁华被夏洛给压制了。
那这场戏也看一眼吧，也就是说夏洛跟秋雅正式要走在一起了啊，全部被压制。另外呢大锤追求冬梅夏洛在天台上向这个假的秋雅表白啊，做了一场信息差的误会戏，做了一场误会戏。来第1六拍第53分钟，夏洛被娜姐带走。这场戏呢讲夏洛要起飞了啊，夏洛人生要起飞了。
但是呢用了一场误会戏去处理啊，做了一个喜剧处理。大家知道一下，第十七拍第1七拍啊，这个正式55分钟进入故事终点。我们说这个故事中前中前部的目标是什么来着？
故事终点啊故事终点秋雅得手了，起始目标达成虚假的胜利，秋雅得手，然后故事要开始急转直下了啊，因为这是个假胜利啊，然后当然这里也展现了一场对手已经暴走了，歇斯底里圆主要对手袁华已经歇斯底里来再看第十八拍啊，第十八拍，也就故事急转直下的第57分钟。
陈凯呢去埋伏夏洛啊，马冬梅暗中牺牲了自己，救下了夏洛啊，威胁升级。第19拍又是一场呼应戏。第19拍第59分钟啊，上一拍马冬梅刚刚暗中牺牲自己，救下夏洛，那么第19拍夏洛这边啊登上了春晚相约酒吧啊，事业达到了巅峰。这里又一组孟太奇啊，成为了大家的骄傲和谈资啊。
到处都是广告牌啊，然后马冬梅悄然离去啊。在这里同学们记一个点有没有人？
认为夏洛登上春晚，大红大紫是这个故事的虚假胜利。有没有人这么认为？首先我先说一下结论，这个电影如愿以偿。
是关于感情的他对自己感情不满意，好吧，她要离婚是他的咒语，所以说回去跟秋雅试一试，才是他的主要目标。首先这是第一点，也就是说，追秋雅甩掉马冬梅才是她回去主要要办的事儿。至于唱歌大红大紫只是辅助。当然了，一般来说，爱情得意，事业也得意啊，一般来说是伴随着的，但是这部戏并不是。
因为他想强调幸福与事业无关，所以他有个错位，那么我们打点必须打在他的主要目标上，这就是我的结论。第二点，我在告诉你们，为什么有这么多同学想错了，因为有很多同学把事业线习惯性的当成主线。就这种习惯吧是刻在每个人心里的，这也可能与生活有关系啊，咱们生活中就愿意把事业线当成主线。
我们抛开事业线和感情线这么强烈的对比，我给大家举个例子，假设。
我现在是个主角，我现在的任务。
是要。
潜入。
敌军内部偷情报，我要卧底到一个黑帮偷情报，就是这是我的目标。我是个警察。但是我卧底到黑帮之后呢，由于我非常卖力的讨好，非常卖力的融入。
这个黑帮的高层呢提拔我让我当了一个堂主。那你说我的故事的主线到底是偷情报呢，还是在黑帮打拼这这是条事业线呢？这个就非常明确了，同学们都知道会打在偷情报上，对不对？新生代那么这个戏为什么就搞不清楚了呢？是不是同样的道理啊？
然后第二十拍啊第二十拍又Q了一下对手，因为这个对手后面还有用啊。
看一下。
。
好，这场戏什么作用啊有两个作用啊有两个作用。第一，这个对手不能丢，就告诉你这个对手还没完，他后面还要攻击的，明白吗？确实最后一击还是这个对手来的啊，袁华后面还要攻击的，然后呢同时也铺垫了一下后面最大的那个事儿，夏洛是这个这个得了HIV嘛，这个HIV最早是从哪来的。
溯源了一下，能理解我这个逻辑吗？就溯源了一下啊，这场戏主要是这个作用啊第21拍很重要了啊，63分钟用新闻视角啊，用一个客观视角快速的推进信息，表达了什么呢？夏洛此时已经成为音乐教父了啊，都已经可以当评委呀扮比赛呀，出现教父了诚的。
成了一个教父了，但是这个金手指开始失效，或者是开始出现反噬。记不记得？我前面说过啊，呃，我之前讲课的时候说过，如愿以偿这个愿望在故事的中前部对你是个促进，在故事的中后部，对你就是阻碍，开始出现反噬了。什么意思啊？就是你这些创意啊毕竟是偷来的呀。
对吧人家周杰伦出来了，人家原主出来了，周杰伦出道了。
各种危机开始出现了，对吧？舆论危机。而且你想想看，周杰伦已经出来了的话，那留给夏洛可以写的歌也越来越少了。第二2拍第22拍也就是第六65分钟，一场游艇美女派对。这里呢当然了那个呃这个这个夏洛又垂死挣扎，帮华哥写了一首那个粤语版的。
屯儿啊，我的老家就住在这个屯儿，那个别看村别看通这把炸大呀呃暂时化解了危机，但是情况还是急转直下。因为有一个很重要的台词，他开始怀疑秋雅和她的爱情。啊，这场戏非常重要是什么呢？就是他这个爱情，他意识到他这个爱情完全是由金手指得来的。
他这个爱情是个假的，是由金手指得来的啊，就是开始全面崩塌啊，爱情也崩塌了，事业开始崩塌啊，这第二十2拍。
然后既然在崩塌的时候，这时候我们说谁要趁虚而入呀？
全面崩塌了啊，舆论危机、才华危机、爱情危机。在这个时候谁要趁虚而入来，我反派要趁虚而入了啊，一姐梅又来了。
呃，落魄了年华再次登场啊。而且在这里啊，我们的主角竟然把这个最大的反派留在了身边啊，铺垫好了啊，铺垫好了。这里当然还有一个小小的Cback，还又做了首诗啊，这个就不去看了啊，都是些喜剧点喜剧点。24拍也就是第69分钟通过回忆得知马冬梅为自己牺牲了自己的人生。然后心里崩塌了啊，心里崩。
在这里，主角的心理防线彻底崩塌啊彻底崩塌。因为他得知啊马冬梅当年为了自己牺牲了自己的人生，这里还有一个小细细节，他一直保留着马冬梅的标枪，这种道具设计很有意思啊，标枪看起来是一个很凶悍的东西，但它却寄托着爱情是吧？这种道具这种笑点设计，你就是会觉得。
创作者就是。
很厉害，很有劲儿，你知道吗？很有劲儿，保留着一根标枪，思念自己的爱人啊。然后第25拍啊，我们说这里是主角，第24拍是主角系里彻底崩塌。第25拍呢，也就第72分钟，他要去找马冬梅了平行世界冬梅她跟马冬梅住的那个地方去寻找马冬梅马冬梅竟然。
在原本的生活轨迹上生活，住着以前的房子和以前一样拔罐，和以前一样做回乡面。但是。
大春出现了，马冬梅已经永远不再属于自己了，属于大春，这是自己埋下了恶果，无奈退出啊无奈退出。上一场心里崩塌，这一场实际崩塌啊，因为马冬梅永远不属于他了，属于他最好的朋友大春，所以拿不回来了啊，拿不回来。第26排也就第82分钟垫了一场啊，垫了什么呢？
就是由于这这个片子里面这个歌曲版权实在太多，所以又垫了一场这个对平行剪辑的对比戏。就他在这边继续荒荒淫的生活。马冬梅那边呢继续自己平静的生活，就变了一场对比。简单看一下这场戏其实用处不大啊，用处不算大。但是它是一个单独节拍，我们还是要看一眼。
这场戏是有信息的啊这场戏是有信息的，就是他被背叛了，他的爱情彻底失去了啊。这三坨戏加起来是什么？内心崩塌，也就是说他觉得自己亏欠马冬梅内心崩塌，然后去找马冬梅，发现马冬梅拿不回来已经属于大春了。然后回到自己家呢发现秋雅和袁华把他给绿了这三件事情啊，三组重拳啊，灵欢之也，灵欢的也。
来问一下啊，问一下同学们有没有同学觉得灵魂黑夜是查出HIV的那一刻，因为HRV代表死亡啊，有没有同学这么讲，是不是又被我猜中了，有没有？
为什么我们说故事一定要有主线主线，我们看一个故事，先看目标，一定要先通过目标把主线拎出来，所有的节拍都是在主线上的。
我们说主线上的节拍，主线上是爱情，前半段是追求秋雅，所以虚假的胜利是得到秋雅，后半段是想拿回马冬梅。所以后半段的灵魂黑夜是彻底失去马冬梅。
HRV是辅助，虽然他带着死亡的7息，但你不能你他是个就死亡气息这件事情，它不是刚需，一定要知道故事的主线是个啥，目标是个啥。在这里啊进入了。
灵魂黑夜两头空，竹篮打水第27拍，也就是第84分钟，夏洛发现自己还是忘不了马冬梅，想起了自己曾经发誓红了之后要回报马冬梅。他想起来他在另外一个平行世界。
他也是一个爱创作，爱弹琴的音乐人，但是他只有一个歌迷叫马冬梅。他现在红了，唯一没有回报的就是马冬梅，唯一亏欠的就是马冬梅他回报了所有人，但是所有人都背叛了她唯一不背叛的她的马冬梅，她却没有回报。
就是戏剧张力啊，把他拉到极致，他红了以后造福了所有的人，包括他妈爱打麻将，生活习惯也不好，包括这个秋雅，包括跟他身边的张扬，甚至包括他的仇家圆华，他都帮助他做了一个杂志叫装男人。
他红了之后，他所有人都吃到了他红的呃，他红了之后的红利。
只有唯一一个相信他的人马冬梅没有吃到他的红利。你看在这里把戏剧张力推到极限，明白我说这场戏很重要是为什么吗？唯一一个相信他才华，相信他真实才华的支持他的人，没有吃到他红了的。
这个这个红利。
但是那些相信他虚假才华的人，甚至包括他的对手袁华都在跟在他旁边小腹，而且全都被叛了了，明白吗？所以在这里，他宣布退出。
歌坛啊，烧了自己的海报啊，烧了自己的海报。然后第28拍也就第85分钟，带着一车的向日葵去找马冬梅了啊，找马冬梅呢结果碰上了大春，然后呢贿赂大春带着大春去玩，想要跟大春换马冬梅，想要把自己的一切给大春，跟大春换回马冬梅，被大春给打了，这是第二8拍啊。
第29拍借着大春打了他去医院查出了所谓的HRV，然后呢更加加深了他的众叛亲离。在这里这场众叛亲离啊做的有多么极致呢？他得了HRV以后，他的助理和他妈开始都开始准备继承他的遗产了，明白吗？他的助理和他妈已经为。
他死了之后的这个这个都开始做打算了，对吧？他助理跟了他这么长时间，现在要得到他所有的遗产了。这场戏啊咱就不说写的。
这个卯的很紧是吧？以这个台词简直是太棒了，短时间内输出这么多称呼，给我们带来这么多笑料。我们就说这三个演员的演技啊简直都是如入画境，每一个细微表演都精准到不行。我跟你说，这种戏非常难演，其实很多同学没有演过喜剧，你不知道啊，写喜剧当然有难度。
演喜剧也很难。这一场戏啊，这三个喜剧演员，这其实不是喜剧演员，夏洛他妈以前没怎么演过喜剧，对吧？人家演演大宅门，演演演正剧的。然后张扬呢其实主要做幕后啊，他演戏也不算多啊。
呃，然后腾哥那肯定喜剧大拿是毫无问题。但是这三个人配合的这场喜剧真的是哎呀，我跟你说，张扬平常生活中也没这么多话是吧？都是很内向的人，但是这喜剧真的是。
其实我们就是这场戏的作用啊，就是集中展现啊嗯这个夏洛已经众叛亲离了啊，甚至都吐血晕倒了，流鼻血啊。然后第30拍来到92分钟，春秋去冬来。然后呢，他在医院已经住了很长时间了，在垂危的时候了啊，大春和冬梅翻墙来看望夏洛。
啊，翻墙来看吧下洛在这里。
冬梅向夏洛袒露了心声啊，你说。
万日之间。
其实挺逗的啊。
我是喜欢上你。
其实这么多年，你写了那么多首歌。
知道我最喜欢的就是当年你送给秋雅那首。
我唱给你听啊。
好，赏戏啊。然后第31拍95分钟，夏洛回到了现实生活啊，也回到了婚礼现场，他不再在乎面子，不再在乎秋雅，不再在乎任何人的眼光。眼里只有马冬梅，这是第31拍啊，第32拍来到97分钟，我们说最后的这个蒙太奇。
97分钟开始最后的这个蒙太奇这个。
阐述了我们的主题，也就是珍惜眼前人啊，平平淡淡就是真。珍惜眼前人，平平淡淡就是真。我们来看一下最后这个王奈姐。
写字儿的，你注意点场合行不行？
原谅。
起那些每天每天每夜每日的守候，别回头。
走。
就表达简简单幸两。
嗯。
幸福的生活啊，这个夏洛甜甜腻歪的马冬梅啊，呃这就是整个戏的节拍啊，嗯我分了32排呃，启程转合非常的明确啊，然后分钟数也基本都卡的准啊，分钟数基本都卡的挺准的。因为毕竟是一个很商业的片子。我们来说一下这部片子为什么分儿不高啊。